i'm so excited for our next guest he has
been on the show this is his third time
and he played here early he first zoomed
to visit us uh virtually from la and we
did like a whole battle of the bites
which parlays into what he's going to do
later today
and then we've done another segment with
him i love this man um he is an amazing
comedian in incredible movies and he's
literally here to dish about his later
latest project um that is kind of really
water cooler and everybody's talking
about it called the after party with an
extraordinary cast it's a real who'd
done it i think it's going to be huge
check it out
do you remember when i let you watch
deadpool 2 and you promised you wouldn't
tell mom yeah
this is like that
operation koala extract is a go
i don't want to be nephetistic but i
love this man and he's so good in this
show get out here
[Applause]
third time i just found out the only
person that's been on this show more
than me gail king
and gail i'm coming for you
okay
i'm sorry miss king i was a joke she's
so wonderful she is even though she took
my best friend from me
oprah um
uh she's a wonderful woman and i wish
you're nothing but the best it's funny i
was telling her the other day i was like
you're such a good friend i was like
you're literally the person behind the
saying that's my gail that's my guilt
you're the gayle you're the gayle that's
amazing but you're the ike yes thank you
and i loved that clip which actually
leads me to my first discussion with you
because i've been dying to talk to
another parent about this
is it true that you let your daughter
foster yes watch
movies also yes we were very uh for many
years we'd only let them watch like
disney stuff then you get to a point
where you're kind of tired and and the
other two are sharing the little two
ones are sharing a room and the older
one comes downstairs and she's like
they're talking i can't sleep and what a
good parent would do is walk upstairs
and say any more sounds there's no more
christmas
and and lay down like some you know some
rules but we were just like oh do you
just want to watch mayor of east town
with us
um which is a great show the best loved
it the best not
good for children
to watch maybe the age dependent eight
that's right foster is eight she's eight
so i would say the proper age for a kid
to watch mayor of east towns oh 16 17.
but we let our eight-year-old do it and
um she she loves kate winslet now
and then i have a minivan proudly yes if
the door doesn't open that way i don't
want anything to do with it yeah yeah
yeah and if you don't have a third row
get out of my face you can't do it and
they sit in the third row we all have
our space you got a cooler in there
there's gear give it up for the third
row guys
right here with water in case there's an
earthquake i got it all figured out me
too
but i put movies on for them in the car
and i've got them locked in there
and i'm like you don't have to watch it
you can look out the window and i will
curate great movies for them
so i grew up on watching everything
everything who wasn't a kid in the 70s
and 80s and wasn't watching like slasher
films and blah blah blah oh my god
trading places halloween like i watched
all these movies that was breakfast and
it was fine it was a different time and
we all turned out okay
yes but you're creating some boundaries
with social well i just think the only
social i want them looking at are fan
pages for me
i don't want them going on weird things
but if there's someone has created let's
say ike baron holt's fan on instagram
and they want to go look at some nice
photos of their dad i'm fine with that
so i have a i blocked every every uh
instagram page but my own fan page right
a lot of which i maintain myself
so we should all be the presidents of
our own family that way i'm in charge of
what people are seeing i give exclusive
behind the scenes content
and that's all i let my kids look at
they're not looking at anything else
[Music]